here we go 15 seconds remaining war zone
Kings let's get there we go there was 15
seconds left you see this thing over
here I'm glad I was here 15 6 you have
to get here 15 seconds early anymore
ha ha see that you see that I have to
get here 15 seconds early if you're you
got it you got to get to your
appointments early here you got to get
to those a little bit early can I get
the c2 part to take here pawn push I
want to keep the night away I don't want
him to get to eat for I want my night to
get here right here and actually here
next let's jump in right to this square
light square Bishop back them up let's
do this in pawn push take that clean
take this clean ok what am I even doing
with that
come here pawn push let's try that okay
now the pawn push here we're just King
up really just want to get my King in a
better position right here kill that
night push my pawns connect it passed
pawn this guy's flying connected passed
pawn rook here take this pawn
I have everything covered don't I pawn
push King up get out of pins whoa
I think it's okay that bishops in a pin
now he's in a pin my rooks are there
pawn push very soon they're gonna resign
they resigning back to turn with 20 what
20 Wow somebody has 20 points and within
2 not even two minutes that is crazy
is this guy even gonna move a non mover
okay I already have this move in let's
do some home prep what is going
20 okay that game oh I guess it was a I
won that one because of the 15-second
roll you got to move within 15 seconds
or you get forfeited I think that's how
it worked that's why I had six points
right there's beginning the question I
was like wait I only played one game and
I had six points I actually played two
so I have two games in six points where
it is mine that you want to go get that
out of there dark square Bishop land hit
the clean with tempo hang on to this
pawn he's important okay Bishop check
Bishop check Queen out leading to mate
soon very soon very very soon very very
soon I don't care I just don't want to
take him that's me dr. Turman 12 or now
2017 14 I of 12 oh man
okay collabs clubs chess okay Smith Mora
gambit
Smith more gambit we have declined they
don't want any of them okay so Knight d5
eventually could come about even if
there might be some sacrifice rook e1
types of stuff Oh actually rook c1 in 95
rook c1 in conjunction with that oh no
oh no am I getting fishing poles oh man
it's close to happening Knight checked
it's not really working
let's back up the night's gonna go here
what was he what does he have up his
sleeve here right here would even work
let's just rule that out for your the
fishing pole fear that fishing pole okay
here we go here we go f7 f7 I want a pin
point f7 can I do that very quickly I
want to play Bishop d3 to stop Bishop f5
to mask my pressure on f7 whoa
why does that Queen have to be so active
get out of there they were threatening
this ma'am that's not working I try that
Bishop here rook here I should have done
that sooner okay I got it
it's working now it's working out I
should have done that move sooner okay
time time time time time time anything
just push anything anything anything no
time
just give it a check like that
whoa that's leading to me that's a cool
one I'll take it back to term in twenty
thirty twenty four twenty sixteen twenty
five less than twenty five Bigfoot
Bigfoot is in town okay let's sneak this
in here ninety-six Queen c7o
Bishop before pin a knight and
threatening that pond maybe I could get
d5 in I should have maybe done d5 right
away I want to get to c4 to hit the dark
square bishop
I like this Knight right here he's very
annoying don't don't take this Knight
because the bishop is kind of out of
play I should just take in this first
problems just do that they're gonna give
up the light square bishop okay my light
square bishop wants to be a beast now he
wants to be a beast get this Knight out
of here and then finish up with the fork
a fork right here grab that rook hit
this Knight and then push the pawn so
that there is no Queen checks on this
diagonal so f5 next expand in the center
or maybe not I want to keep these pawns
sitting there boxing out the Knights
really well
flight square throw in a clean check I'm
actually on the night you might want to
throw in another check we could this is
another mate look at how similar this is
this is the second time there's these
two diagonals going towards my opponents
King whoa these guys are like lasers
those diagonals watch out for them they
are deadly okay 30 28 25 23 minutes
remaining
King on pre beat me to the punch right
there he definitely beat me to the punch
okay Bishop c4 Knight takes pawn we're
gonna have that
okay now I stopped against that f4
Knight f3 castle play on the F file I
have three I'm gonna get that F file
this is reminding me of that Simon I had
earlier where I ended up losing that one
there's a pretty good bet I lost that
one pretty good bet for sure okay look
back let's pin this night he was ready
to be annoying keep this night out of
here
keep the pins jump a night in here take
my night I win material okay let's keep
this guy around night back I go ripped
or 1994 book d2 rook f2 to watch over
this let's open files and a3 is not how
you open a file you need to engage that
was a mouse slip that was a mouse Lipper
ruski 94 let's try it again light
squares I could want to get this my
bishop right here some skewer maybe back
all the way up I don't want this night
to be able to capture okay let's come
here if I push the knight jumps here I
want to get that night up there he's I
gotta take him if he goes here
just take them give me this pawn is
there a queen gonna defend I could hit
it again keep the bishop on this
diagonal we might have another diagonal
sort of issue rook takes pawn okay
threatening maids probably this is
checkmate one two I get the Queen at the
very least the very least I get the
Queen this feels like it should be made
though it's gonna be made right here is
me they resigned another down time I
think 42 30 30 30 21 minutes remaining
again Bigfoot is here yeah it's Bigfoot
like the assassin should everybody fear
a Bigfoot like they should be fearing
the assassin okay let's get it fired up
here let's get it fired up let's see how
Bigfoot defends I really still want to
do that okay let's open this up can I
get this point oh boy
okay I was ready to like push here I
think there might be some sack pawn push
bishop check let's get castle before
it's too late
open things up and my queen is pinned so
let me her yeah I was pinned on this
file so I want to defend my queen pawn
push for Bishop here that bishop moves I
get this pawn hmm and just do that I
want to put pressure on that beep on D
pawn pressure right here
his pawn is gonna be a bit annoying I'm
gonna take the Queen's whoa no no don't
you dare drop the roof the knight has to
take it didn't take I have flight square
for my King right here on the knight
got to do something the knight moves
then my knight moves I'm looking for me
taking this pawn and then pushing my H
pawn I'm gonna do this cuz there might
be some rook check or something it's
guard knight here push push push
it's close to me very close to me
that's mate next that's a cool one back
to tournament 56:49 42s 19 minutes
remaining
okay a lot of time a lot of time in this
one why am i starting out with d4 in
these games okay oh no a non mover
I'm non mover let me see my closest
my closest rival is where
oh I keep forgetting back to Terman I
shouldn't go there's no more time for
doing um homework here because the game
finishes in 15 seconds I'm thinking that
I have like a minute I don't I'm
forgetting about that this guy is up
there he is having a good tournament 36
points is pretty good Oh
94 94 soon okay you're not so soon I
really want to do it I really want to do
that one I'm gonna try it now because I
capture with tempera on the bishop and
the h2 square opens up it's an
interesting moment to do it like that
looking to get rid of the dark square
Bishop h2 oh man h2 has seen the Queen
landing on what am I trying to say the
Queen has seen the h2 square many a
times many times pressure on this point
pressure points just castle
okay put pressure on this pawn capture
more pressure what I want to have a pawn
around here okay this is definitely
scary the Queen's gonna come out let's
do this bishops gonna be annoying Bishop
is definitely gonna be annoying I feel
like I need to do that I'm dropping upon
but oh boy oh boy I'm in trouble
Oh Queen trade I love Queen trades I
love those Queen trades I really do
they're my favorite they're my favorite
everybody loves a Queen trade nobody
loves a queen trade more than me promise
you I promise you that
talking about bishop here I kick it away
kick it away it's actually trapped I
could take it with my pond and be on the
rook they might resign pile up on that
pond with check they resigned back to
tournament one 1093 mr. nut who is that
William B is on the scene okay
Smith Maura okay there's a video I did
where there's the Siberian trap and I
also showed a way that you can implement
the fishing pole in that one video oh I
wanted to break in the center with stop
casting maybe this no f3 would have been
played
you're gonna go Queen side they're gonna
have to bail Queen side and I'm looking
to get rid of that LightSquared bishop
this guy needs to develop though let's
go Bishop here Oh what's going on with
that move pawn push and my bishop
getting trapped no not really just open
this up Knight takes is available
there's pins everywhere take on that
square open this up
come on c3 my bishop could play here
pawn push rook here just do that I'm not
100% perfect percent 100 percent sure
why but I am going to do it pin this
night and now I'm on this pun a lot of
what's with all these diagonals what's
with all these diagonals in these games
pins free Queens bishops everything's
falling domino effect everything
everything everything everything
I gotta go quicker here they resigned
back to tournament 130 120 130 120 113
less than 15 collabs okay here we go
I'm going with d4 again can I turn this
into some gambit are they gonna move
they aren't gonna move
okay let's get I want to get an e for e
4e for I got e for in alright there's
are gonna be a queen check there might
be a queen check night takes I could
actually that's working out its back up
Bishop d3 okay I'll take could have
maybe considered not taking since I had
a space advantage there okay
is it really matter where I how I
captured me I should have pushed I want
to be annoying with my knight on c5 and
this there probably wanted to keep my
knight away okay if they take they're in
trouble I get this okay that Knight is
caught in a crossfire sort of he's
without a home my queen is very active
my rook is unprotected on that night
again passed pawns
I can't move my knight I'm hitting their
Knight
I need a flight square still get rid of
this Knight the tricky Knight needs to
go it's just defends stuff all I want to
do is defend take with the pond not the
rook I need a flight square I still need
a flight square I still need a flight
square ok the rook is gonna play there
but I could play back just do this and
then this and then get my pawn pushing I
just want to get pushing here let's just
check I get that rook and then come back
to defend everything and get my pawn
pushing push this pawn push him no
matter what
throw a check maybe another check get
the Queen's off clean trade oh kitchen
sink they resigned back to tournament
150 140 12 minutes remaining
ok I've done 12 minutes 30 seconds
ah man another close one hopefully this
one finishes don't quick resign to me
whatever you do I think that was the
problem in that last game or something
that was a weird weird glitch
can I get b2 quick kill on beat two
quick kill on B to check that dark
square bishop I got that dark square
bishop on the night I want to sneak in
somehow
can I sneak in huh and go back I think
there would have been a rook move here
or something bishop here oh that's a
killer that is definitely a killer I
didn't want to open up this diagonal
that's why I captured like this hit the
pin piece attack pink pieces don't
capture him
if he's still pinned after this okay
take with the King taking with the Queen
drops my Bishop King position stop the
knight from getting excited about that
square he's probably still gonna go
there
attack the Queen attack that Queen and
run over here King it's safe over here
over here over here's where you want to
be I think oh that's pinned they
couldn't take it I'm on the rook they
resigned back to tournament 170 160 11
minutes remaining 13 games dr. meadow
dr. meadow okay here we go
d3 this is very intense very very
intense game these are good it's let me
pin this guy I don't want 94 stuff
oh he's not pinned anymore he's gonna
kill me oh no no no I'm in trouble
I'm in trouble I can feel it I'm in
trouble no I'm not I think I'm okay oh
no pawn push
I got a castle soon castle soon or you
gonna die castle soon or prepare to be
killed
uh-oh where are the tricks where are
those tricks get out of the tricks the
night was ready to kill me I don't want
to take them I want to get it this
square can I get there what my sin you
just defend is this working and hit the
Queen hit the Queen I can maybe take the
rook and some lines ah I can't think
hit the Queen get out of there look at
the clock
oh man okay pins pins pins pins can I
get this pine I'm not even attacking
that pond what does that move even do
what does that loo even do I can't
regroup here regroup I can't even
regroup can I give a check on f6 please
okay can I make something work here are
the mains or the mains give a check
oh I'm David Blaine in it again well I
got a Brooke how much time I got a queen
that's good
I got a queen that's always nice to see
they're down on time packed a tournament
180 didn't I get point uh no they just
got they got two more games in 180 170 I
have to catch up I have to catch up that
could be a huge game that oh it's two
hundred now it's two hundred I'm thirty
points out ah that is a lot of points to
overtake I need a quick kill that game
went down to the wire
dr. meadow that's the second very very
strong game my opponent put up there oh
I got the bishop move Knight oh my queen
is hit ah man
pollen push I take here are they gonna
do that pawn push you know you want to
chase my net away you know you want to
chase my night away you know you want to
chase my night away we can g3o it's a
free money on this they get my knight
but I get this Knight are they gonna
resign they're not resigning pawn push
open up this age file open this up
Bishop here okay
okay I take here checkmate if they take
yes quick quick quick quick quick just
move don't be a non mover just move okay
they move back determine 210 whoa
210 I guess it just didn't didn't
register last time 210
I got cata pulled it up there 210 I'm in
the lead leave I mean leave can I keep
the lead is the question it's the big
question okay why am I playing Queens
gambit declined lines in war zone come
on man
come on you could do better than that
you could play more dynamically can't
you get a majority get the pawns rolling
tricky Forks actually it's not for
tricky discoveries and I'm dropping upon
I think where am I
sneak attack uh I'm on the Queen let's
back up I want to hit the Queen I want
to hit that Queen they're gonna take
their would you take their already over
here maybe I shouldn't take it like that
Oh tricky night I got a bishop Oh
the Queen's trapped I could have some
fun against the Queen Queen d8 I take
here I dance back and forth
I got everything sealed off right here
just for fun just for fun flight square
right here Queen position
Knight position what's my bishop doing
he could do something better stop that
stop it get out of there
get out of there right here Queen to
Bishop takes pawn Bishop takes pawn
crashing through no okay I could have
done that Hoda Benari push just push
push push
clean check no stalemates gonna resign
where's the where's the win check that's
me back to chairman 2:30 2:30 2:30
oh they have an extra game in they have
a they're winning on tiebreaks to 30 to
35 minutes remaining 522 are we gonna
get paired up that's gonna be intense
let me tell you you think it's fun to
watch do you think it's exciting to
watch
oh man the adrenaline rush imagine just
imagine just imagining I'll get your
adrenaline going right just start to
imagine it just imagine if we get paired
up wow that's gonna be dangerous isn't
it that is gonna be very dangerous
it's gonna be one of the most dangerous
games around
Oh tricky bishops what's my rook even
doing he's gonna get kicked away the
knight wanted to go to f3 anyhow oh okay
at the end of this room I get what do I
get I get the rook and I get control of
the only open file let me throw a tricky
check-in hey wait it might happen again
why what's happening again this is three
in a row the deadly diagonal tournament
whoa
deadly diagonals you gotta watch out for
those are they gonna resign they're not
resigning whoa
Oh No look at this look at these antics
oh no no no no no to 70 oh man
to 70 a non movers killing me here this
is me I'm getting Nona fried right to
zero is there any hope is there any hope
to 70 to 30 how much time is remaining
3:45 this guy's killing me
look at these antics look at these
antics back determine 290 oh that's
tough to catch that is very tough to
catch when there's less than four
minutes remaining sneak attack take my
pond I gotta go for cheap tricks now
very cheap tricks very very cheap tricks
is what I'm looking for right now
very cheap take that pond is actually
okay I can't play my rip there oh maybe
they're not seeing it uh-oh uh-oh big
problems block with the Queen I give a
check I guess I got to do it like that
it's not gonna be a quick win it's not
gonna be a quick win nope
okay that's actually just giving back
material this guy is up there
I gotta settle down I have to settle
down here take that bishop that was a
free bishop that's a free pawn also take
this defend here give me that
gimme gimme gimme rook right here defend
stuff defend stuff okay they were gonna
ready to double up over there
double rooks Double Trouble okay they're
gonna get this I'm gonna get that
wonderful commentary they're gonna get
this I'm gonna get that oh man I can't
win this race with cheque I need more
checks my king is cut off I got a run I
got a run run run pawn run pawn my King
needs to book he's got a book oh I
didn't even stop the Queen I was
supposed to stop the Queen I still post
I was supposed to stop the cleaning from
occurring oh it's just gonna be a drop
if I'm lucky if I'm lucky if I'm lucky
and it's not working out is it oh hang
on
oh it's a draw oh man I wasn't even
gonna catch him 310 is amazing 310 is up
there ahhh Wow
less than a minute this game isn't even
gonna finish even if I got that one whoa
is it my move
this guy's not moving ah let's then oh
there's only like 45 seconds that could
be called like probably any second oh
man that was a wild game that was really
really wild did I get a g2 somehow 9595
tricky discoveries where does that mate
where is that main main to threat main
to difficult to defend anything just go
there not even to give me that win there
Colin its second place confetti oh oh
that was tense for a while good games
off 310 that was fantastic 21 games out
of 21 is really good 310 - 52:29
208 wow this guy that was that drawn
game that I had that was insane okay it
games good games good games